Fireflies have a very nice example here
where the female firefly does not fly but
sits on a tree in the jungle.
And watches the sky and the male flies along
flashing a winking light,
at a rate that is characteristic for that
species.
When the female sees the right rate flying
overhead then she winks back.
He recognises this and flies down to her.
It's a beautiful way of bringing two very
small animals together
in a large tract of countryside.
There's the male.
Started flashing as he flew off.
You see the luminescent organ is at the back
of his abdomen.
Flashing a characteristic message, rather
like Morse code.
And here is a female answering back.
And in a moment we'll see them side by side.
There they are.
They've met up and they're still flashing
away in a courtship signal.
Now it's been found that if you do this very
carefully,
you can use a small torch to pretend that
you're a female firefly
and call a male down.
The male has come down to the experimenter's
hand there.
Every time it flashes he waits for a moment
and then flashes back.
The firefly came over to the torch.
And now he moved the torch and called it back.
There can be a nasty end to that story though.
Because the female fireflies of some species
are very carnivorous.
And they wink at males of other species.
So the male flies down thinking he's found
himself a girlfriend
to find he gets gobbled up.
It's really not nice.
The way in which these animals make their
light is extremely interesting.
Because they do it by a chemical process,
mixing two chemicals together
which then produces a very great deal of light.
I have here two such chemicals that when mixed
will produce light.
I've always wanted to do this demonstration
and now's my chance.
I'll pour them now into this funnel and just
watch what happens.
Isn't that beautiful?
And it continues to glow in the big reservoir
down here.
Now if I take the funnel, it's still quite
cold.
We're used to thinking of light sources as
having to be hot.
But this chemical reaction produces very little
heat.
All the energy of the reaction goes into the
production of light.